[Music]
you went off on this horseshit about you
not doing ad I can't
I don't undo it I don't know what you
did an ad do you know what I'm talking
about do you know what I'm talking about
not I'm not in America I mean not in
America no it was not an ad in America
where was where's this ad from this
Britain ringabel
United Kingdom United Kingdom ladies and
gentlemen let's take a look
no yes let's take it here you said you
didn't good let's take a look at Bob
Odenkirk ad from the United Kingdom
Caroline I may be an antihero but you
should know something
I'm your antihero cut great work mister
Odenkirk it's in the cab
heck yeah it's in the can hi I'm Bob
Odenkirk dramatic acting can take a lot
out of you middle of the day your acting
can lose its oomph
that's when I grabbed for a can of
Gables wet pee comestibles it's just a
simple one two three four and out it
comes Gables is the only wet Pete
concoction that is packaged in an
airtight can and not in an old-fashioned
plastic slurry pouch that's what makes
HP boggy and sappin in good measure an
American that means wet and tasty
he got peach time is meatza it's time to
I'm not done okay it's time to a mode
again I'm fake brain I'm all ready to go
thanks to Gables wet Peas available at
your corner shop with Ebel's
it's always in the can giggles wet be
comestibles
not to be served to dogs
[Music]
that was like I signed it not supposed
to show in America that's what's shown
in America right by the way that was
Andy's voice I think no that's an Andy
sound oh I hear if everyone rips off
Andy in commercials
yeah I actually don't think I actually
thought the doctrine value is great yeah
yeah yeah no I know what you mean I
don't know it's got a very it's got a
very cheap quality almost as if it was
shot like an hour ago
right over there all right hard to
achieve that's very hard to achieve I
don't think that commercials gonna hurt
you Bob I really don't know I think it's
the outtakes from that commercial I did
when they go viral that's gonna hurt you
how are they let's take a look Caroline
I may be an antihero what Caroline I may
be an antihero I've got my eyes closed
this woman is not a Caroline look at me
but not like that Caroline I may be an
antihero who says that did summer remind
me to keep my eyes open
thank you keep it steady it's a movie
I may be an antihero but guess what I'm
you're who wrote this crap guess what
who says guess what - in an intimate
conversation you wrote this bubble I
wrote this okay okay cut great work not
faster hi I'm Bob Odenkirk and I just
learned my own goddamn name come on
cut if the woman okay
that's when I grab for a can of Gables
wet which camera do I look at hand it to
me hand it to me
of cables wet pee don't stick it my face
am I supposed to empty for wool eat I
know I'm supposed to do why did you
write eat on this with Peebles it's
always in the can that was great right
that's gonna tell you some peas
[Applause]
you